what exactly is your relationship with
robert birchdoll
well he's
he's practically a member of the family
good morning brobergs good morning
morning
good morning jan it's gonna be a great
day hey who do you love the most
[Music]
tell you the truth a man like you a
father and a church leader i wanted to
be friends with you from the moment i
met you really
i almost feel like we're two sides of
the same family
i look at you and marianne
and
sometimes i wish i had the kind of
marriage you have
if you really care about me broker
please help me out brother
no one thinks that their best friend is
a monster
but he has all the hallmarks of a
psychopathic personality
happy birthday jan
robert berchtol doesn't feel emotions
the way that we do
[Music]
he will lie and manipulate to get the
only thing that he wants
you remember what i told you i sure are
special
who is her father
him or me
gail
if you knew something
you would tell us right
your husband kidnapped her again
there's no telling what he is capable of
[Music]
you